In 2019, Sundar Pichai took home a compensation
of $281 million dollars or a little over a
quarter billion dollars.
There are of course founder CEOs and hedge
funds managers that blow that number out of
the water.
The one key difference between these top earners
and Sundar, however, is that Sundar didn’t
found his own company or hedge fund.
In fact, Sundar didn’t join Google until
2004 and when he did join, he was simply a
manager.
Moreover, Sundar didn’t have any high level
connections or very much money when he came
to the US.
Sundar quite literally started at the very
bottom and worked his way up the corporate
ladder to the very top.
So, here’s how Sundar Pichai became the
#1 paid employee in the world starting with
nothing.
Taking a look back, Sundar was born on June
10, 1972 in Chennai India.
His father was an electrical engineer and
his mother was a stenographer.
It doesn’t seem like the family had any
financial problems per se, but they weren’t
rich by any means.
The family lived in a small two room apartment
and Sundar and his brother would sleep in
the living room.
Though Sundar’s background wasn’t particularly
helpful for him, his intellect would prove
extremely helpful.
From a very young age, Sundar was extremely
bright with one his most notable characteristics
being his insane memory.
Apparently, Sundar was able to recall every
single number he ever dialed on their home
rotary phone.
Considering this, it’s not too surprising
that Sundar would end up attending the Indian
Institute of Technology or IIT where he studied
metallurgical engineering.
After IIT, Sundar scored a spot at Stanford
where he got masters in engineering and material
science.
He didn’t stop right there either.
Sundar turned around and tried to get a Phd
from Stanford, but he soon decided that gaining
work experience was probably the better bet.
So, he dropped out of his doctoral program
and got a job at Applied Materials as an engineer/product
manager in the late 1990s.
He didn’t stick around at Applied Materials
for too long though as he quickly shifted
over to McKinsey & Company.
Around the same time, Sundar decided that
getting an MBA would further propel his career.
So, he would end up attending the Wharton
School of Business and secure an MBA.
A few years later in 2004, Sundar would attend
an interview at Google on April Fools Day.
Ironically, before applying to Google himself,
Sundar had convinced one of his friends to
not apply to Google.
This was during the height of the dotcom crash
where over 90% of internet companies went
bankrupt.
So, Sundar’s warnings made sense, yet he
ironically ended up applying himself.
His interview actually took place on the day
that Google launched Gmail, and given that
it was April fool’s day, like many, Sundar
thought that Gmail was just a joke.
Anyway, Sundar of course got the job, and
he started working as a product manager overlooking
Google’s search toolbar development.
A lot of us don’t even remember that Google
used to have such a toolbar.
But, at the time, this was actually a major
development.
You see, just two years later in 2006, Microsoft
made Bing the default search engine on Internet
Explorer.
However, since many Google users had the Google
search toolbar installed, Google was able
to heavily reduce the effects of Microsoft’s
decision.
So, by chance, Sundar found himself working
on one of the most important developments
for Google at the time.
Aside from being able to play a key role in
the young company, this experience made Sundar
realize how dependent Google was on Microsoft.
If Microsoft had made this decision a few
years ago, Google may not have become so popular
in the first place.
So, in an effort to minimize risk moving forward,
Sundar would suggest creating a browser.
Most of the managers and executives above
him didn't really like this idea.
Sure, having a popular browser would give
Google a major upper hand, but it seemed like
it was simply way too late to enter the browser
game.
Internet Explorer had literally come out over
a decade ago and even Safari and Firefox had
been out for multiple years.
So, much of Google’s management didn’t
think developing a browser was a viable idea.
Two guys, however, were willing to enforce
the idea and this was of course Google’s
founders’ Larry Page and Sergey Brin.
Larry and Sergey knew that Google’s success
had never come from being first.
They were 8 years late to search engines and
they were actually 33 years late to the email
scene.
In fact, when they bought YouTube, they didn’t
even buy the earliest video sharing platform.
The first video sharing platform called shareyourworld.com
came out in 1997 while YouTube wasn’t even
launched till 2005.
So, clearly, Google was never the first one
on the scene.
Yet, given Google’s early success, it was
clear to Larry and Sergey that being first
didn’t necessarily determine the success
of a product or service.
So, Larry and Sergey encouraged Sundar to
give the browser a shot.
Sundar and his team would develop Google Chrome
over the next few years with a few key targets.
The first target was creating an unbeatable
UI.
Google had already built up a name for being
the cool kid on the block.
They offered more storage, more services,
and a better user experience than any of their
competition.
So, Chrome had to live up to these customer
expectations.
Fortunately for Sundar, this wasn’t too
difficult as Internet Explorer was pretty
clunky at the time.
The UI wasn’t Sundar’s only focus though.
He knew that in order to attain long term
sustained success, Chrome had to be a developer
favorite.
Instead of trying to guess what web developers
liked, Sundar decided to let developers show
him what they liked through Chromium.
Chromium is an open source web browser that
was launched in September of 2008.
This allowed Sundar’s team to easily implement
input from developers from around the world,
and as you would guess, this made Google Chrome
extremely stable and fast.
Combine this with a far superior UI, and switching
to Chrome was a no brainer for most people.
Despite the successful launch of Chrome, Sundar
never limited himself to just one project.
In the background, he was also laying the
foundation for other fundamental products.
One of these endeavors was Google Drive.
Google had already stepped into the office
products space in 2006 with the launch of
Google Docs, Google Sheets, and Google Slides.
While these products weren’t nearly as robust
as Microsoft’s offerings, they were completely
free which attracted a large number of casual
users.
In 2010, Google acquired a company called
DocVerse which allowed multiple people to
collaborate on documents.
While this was an intriguing idea, the impletemation
wasn’t quite right.
Sundar, however, had the perfect solution
for this: Google Drive.
Instead of storing files locally, google drive
allowed users to store their files on Google’s
data centers which not only made it easy to
collaborate but also easy to access these
files anywhere in the world.
Similar to Google Chrome, Sundar didn’t
invent the cloud by any means.
However, his execution was brilliant.
And that brings us into his third biggest
contribution which was Chrome OS.
Once again, Chrome OS was also not an original
idea.
In fact, Larry Ellison, the founder of Oracle
was trying to create something similar in
the late 1990s called the network computer.
But, Larry found it extremely difficult to
gain much attraction from the market as he
was simply targeting all PC users who wanted
a cheaper machine.
Sundar, however, targeted a super niche market:
students and light users.
Chrome OS didn’t try to compete against
Windows or Mac OS.
There’s no question that Windows and Mac
OS are far better for serious tasks.
But this is actually Chrome OS’s biggest
strength.
By simply focusing on simple computer tasks
and leaving the serious tasks up to Windows
and Mac, Chrome OS was able to nail the simple
tasks for an unbeatable price.
And this has proven extremely attractive to
a niche group of customers.
Given all of these major contributions to
Google, it’s not surprising that Sundar
was promoted to Senior Vice President of Chrome
and apps in 2012.
Just a year later in 2013, Andy Rubin, the
creator of Android, would leave Google, and
Larry Page would give Sundar Pichai the responsibility
of managing the Android division as well.
One of Sundar’s biggest contributions with
Android was Android one which significantly
drove down the cost of entry level smartphones.
Sundar also made Android a much more integrated
part of Google.
Before Sundar took over Android, Android basically
operated as a seperate business that was simply
owned by Google.
Sundar’s influence at Google would slowly
but consistently increase year after year,
and in October of 2014, he was promoted to
Product Chief.
While this is quite a significant position,
many other tech companies were offering Sundar
even higher level positions.
There were some rumors floating around that
Twitter was trying to hire Sundar as CEO in
2015.
It also seems like Microsoft was seriously
considering hiring Sundar as CEO in 2014.
Despite these attractive offers, Sundar decided
to stick to Google, and this would eventually
pay off massively.
In August of 2015, Larry Page and Sergey Brin
decided to step back from Google.
They created a new holding company called
Alphabet, and they became the leaders of Alphabet.
Meanwhile, Sundar was promoted to CEO of Google.
At this point, he was basically the CEO of
the entire company and Larryand Sergey basically
played chairman roles.
But this would become official at the end
of 2019 as Larry and Sergey stepped down from
Alphabet as well, promoting Sundar to CEO
of Alphabet.
And given that Google stock has grown over
260% over the past 5 years, it’s not surprising
that Sundar has received such massive compensation.
So, what can we learn about Sundar’s unstoppable
rise to the top?
Well, the key thing to note about Sundar is
that he’s not particularly notable within
any of the classic character traits.
He’s not an innovative genius like Elon
Musk or Steve Jobs.
Nor is he a creative genius like Steven Spielberg
or James Cameron.
He also wasn’t at the right place at the
right time like Steve Ballmer.
And though Sundar is extremely intelligent,
I don’t necessarily think his success can
be attributed to his intelligence either.
After all, it's not like he’s developing
rocket engines or personally developing self-driving
cars.
But, despite not sticking out in any one of
these categories, Sundar has achieved phenomenal
success and I think that can be attributed
to one thing: unparalleled execution.
He didn’t create browsers, or the cloud,
or smartphones, or even a company for that
matter.
However, Sundar was able to bring every product
he worked on to life better than any of the
competition whether that be through the UI,
the cost to the customer, or the integration
with Google’s other products.
Sundar has proven that you don’t have to
be the first to be the best.
And given that this was basically the foundation
for Google as a whole, I can’t think of
anyone better than Sundar Pichai to lead the
company.
Why do you guys think Sundar is successful?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you think Sundar deserves
his success.
And of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.